it's Saturday Night Live star Sarah
Sherman
why does a circus you have to dress like
a ring leader and I was like yeah I feel
like I'm a little circus poodle and you
brought the circus to town you want to
do some news with us too yeah all right
yeah come on let's go
all right
okay first of all we have to call it out
right away yeah I'm drinking out of
Sarah's mug so we're Xing today Sarah's
news and Drew's news
I'm so in love with Sarah news and it's
like when you're you've got the Two
Worlds Of The Weekend Update backdrop
and then your world yeah and ever since
you came on the scene at SNL you popped
it was like oh she's gonna yeah
the one it's so exciting all right Sarah
news Drews news X will you take our
first story as I drink out of your mug
I mean come on like look at this are we
not meant to be together or what okay go
ahead and read
don't mind if I do uh Harper's bizarre
pretty cool reports that Ben Affleck
Matt Damon Jason Bateman and Bradley
Cooper are in a celebrity world group
chat where they share their daily scores
are you in a celebrity group chat
um
probably oh
no playing a game per se like it there's
no it's more just like God are we ever
gonna get on that weekend trip we've
been planning for the last two or three
years like I definitely I'm in some
group chats where some people of note
might be but then there's a lot of other
people too I don't have this like A-list
game game yeah that cause that is an
A-list game portal yeah I wonder what
their starting word is I bet it's hubba
do you world do you know how it works I
do Wordle and I do have a Wordle group
chat yeah you do I knew it yeah with my
celebrity friends Jack and Dan so I know
everybody really wants to get in that
group chat but I start up every word all
day with the word dream really yeah
because I want to start the day with a
you know what I'm saying positive
affirmation with World Peace you know
what I'm saying what is your start word
Jewell everyone has one I don't I I I I
really don't I mean you should really
but what I if it's the same every day I
don't know you have to be strategic I'll
tell you how to do it all right my my
start word is a do because a d i e u all
the vowels almost right there and I
learn a lot about the word strategy all
right oh well gosh well
magazine is giving me nightmares with
this story about a woman in Australia
who is just going about her business
changing her sheets as we all do when
she found a deadly six foot eastern
brown snake in her bed nope absolutely
no to this throw the whole bed away
Sarah Ross what would you do it's not my
house anymore it's his house
yeah what would put the house on the
market and move to the North Pole that's
what I would do get me away I wanted a
cow king not a king cobra thank you very
much that's my worst nightmare I'm gonna
check the bed tonight it's terrifying
but it's also
good to know that our worst nightmares
can come true yeah they can't come true
host reports on newlyweds who went viral
after their wedding photographer posted
a picture on Facebook of their unusual
budget-friendly choice so instead of
throwing confetti or rice as they left
the ceremony which is traditional they
had guests throw instant mashed potato
powder
and yeah uh it did get wet
things to sweat and spill drinks and on
the floor it turned into a little
Thanksgiving side dish okay
um and I guess the rest of the wedding
was just gravy after that
but stupid
but how about them taters what do you
think do you think uh mashed potato mix
makes cute confetti
um oh
I mean it works
here's the thing also I did a little
research into this it's a lot less
expensive than actual confetti which
doesn't decompose these will basically
disappear into nothingness
um and then it's better for Birds
because rice is not good for birds and
also more expensive so I say
I'm
guess what I could do a little of this
delicious it's good I'm like Sarah I
don't know how you feel about marriage
but I'd like to just you know co-join
with you under some potato buds for life
because
what you put out into the world is
something that I'm just on the feeder of
your funny you're smart you're colorful
you're bright and can we do this more
often Sarah news out here
[Applause]
together
as long as you know you give me bowls of
my own dandruff
well ladies and gentlemen that is it for
news and I can't thank Sarah Sherman
enough for coming here
[Music]
foreign